wir sind doch keine Bananenrepublik das
ist die Republik Türkei sie sagen
erdogan ist ein Diktator aber das ist
mir fremd ich diene dem Volk er führt
uns geradewegs in eine neoliberale
Diktatur das was wir heute in der Türkei
erleben ist ein Albtraum hey Deutschland
ihr habt mit Demokratie nicht in
Geringsten etwas zu tun eure Praktiken
sind nicht anders als die Praktiken der
Nazis seit zwei Jahrzehnten ist Recep
Tayyip Erdogan der starke aber wahrlich
auch umstrittene Mann in der Türkei wie
hat das geschafft seine Macht immer
weiter auszubauen und wie hat er sich
verändert um verstehen zu können wer
Erdogan heute ist hilft es sich seinen
Aufstieg etwas genauer anzuschauen
Erdogan wird 1954 als Sohn aber
Zuwanderer von der schwarzwälteste in
Istanbul geboren schon mit 15 engagierte
sich politisch fällt auf das begabter
Redner mit ausgeprägten politischen
Instinkten wird gefördert und arbeitet
sich hoch
in den 90er Jahren waren seine
Heimatstadt der 12 Millionen Metropole
Istanbul Bürgermeister aus dieser Zeit
stammt auch sein Ansehen bei den Leuten
als effektiver Manager der konkrete
Fragen wie müllprobleme oder die maroden
statt Finanzen erfolgreich anpackte
2001 ist Erdogan Mitbegründer der AKP
der Partei für Gerechtigkeit und
Entwicklung sie verspricht das Land zu
demokratisieren die Partei ist neu und
unverbraucht und genau deshalb hat sie
eine so enorme Anziehungskraft denn die
Türkei hat instabile Zeiten hinter sich
und die Menschen haben genug um
Missmanagement und der Korruption der
etablierten Parteien und nur ein Jahr
nach Gründung der AKP zahlte sich aus
der Fluss der Bevölkerung hat der
islamischen akpartei die absolute
Mehrheit im Parlament beschert
Erdogan darf zu der Zeit nicht ins
Parlament gewählt werden weil er aus
einem religiösen Gedicht zitiert hat die
zitierten Zeilen gelten als
Volksverhetzung dafür sitzt er 1999
sogar einige Monate im Gefängnis 2003
hebt die AKP des Verbot auf Erdogan
zieht doch noch ins Parlament ein und
wird
Ministerpräsident demokratische Reformen
eine Öffnung zum Westen und
wirtschaftliche Höhenflüge sorgten für
Wohlstand und Wachstum in allen
Bevölkerungsschichten Erdogan wird von
westlichen Politikern und Politikerinnen
gelobt und die Türkei wird offiziell EU
Beitrittskandidat und auch innerhalb des
Landes wird er von vielen gefeiert der
starke Mann der Türkei mischt sich gern
unter die kleinen Leute deren hält er
ist der religiöse Ministerpräsident
verspricht zwar ein Liberalen modernen
Islam Gegner aber haben Angst vor einer
Islamisierung des türkischen Alltags
nicht zuletzt weil Religion unter der
AKP ein immer höheren Stellenwert in den
Lehrplänen der Schulen bekommt und die
strenge Trennung zwischen Religion und
Staat aufgeweicht wird mehr als 300.000
Menschen demonstrierten gegen eine
mögliche Kandidatur Erdogans für das Amt
des Staatspräsidenten sie befürchten
eine Islamisierung des Landes sollte der
islamisch konservative Politiker in das
Amt kommen letztendlich wirkt der
Protest und Erdogan kandidiert nicht für
das Präsidentenamt das hält ihn aber
nicht davon ab seine Macht
innenpolitisch weiter auszubauen und
sich in eine andere Richtung zu
entwickeln Experten und Expertinnen sind
sich uneinig darüber wann genau Erdogans
Verwandlung beginnt fest steht aber er
wendet sich vom Westen ab und sein
Regierungsstil nimmt zunehmend Autorität
eine Rolle dürften dabei die
Enttäuschungen spielen die die
erfolglosen Verhandlungen mit der
Europäischen Union gebracht hat treibt
Erdogan der neue starke Mann der Türkei
auf Reisen unermüdlich klappert er die
europäischen Hauptstädte in Sachen
EU-Beitritt ab doch die Gespräche enden
in türkischer Frustration den zweiten
Grund für die Verwandlung sehen Experten
in Erdogans Angst vor macht Verlust er
tut alles um die Kontrolle zu behalten
Gegner dritte immer härter entgegen
offensichtlich wird das 2013 als ein
Massenproteste gegen seine Regierung
blutig niederschlagen lässt oder nicht
das wollen die denn
das wissen wir nicht das Wissen nicht
doch was sie wollen ist klar und das
machen sie auch deutlich weg mit der
regierungskalieren sie weg mit Erdogan
Kompromissbereitschaft scheint Erdogan
aus seinem Charakter gestrichen zu haben
diesen Platz nahm ein Erdogan ein der
kompromisslos auf seiner Meinung Bestand
hart und verbohrt war und auf niemanden
hörte nicht einmal auf die nächsten in
seiner Umgebung
2014 bei der Präsidentschaftswahl und
wird nun doch noch Staatspräsident wir
werden auf diesem Weg weitergehen so
Erdogan dem Volk dienen und die
Demokratie in der Türkei noch weiter
vorantreiben
als Regierungschef hatte alle seine
Versprechen eingehalten der ist gut für
das Vaterland
verschafft sich in seinem neuen Amt des
bisher eher symbolische Bedeutung hat
mehr Macht 2016 steht Erdogan dann
international in der Kritik weil er
zunehmend autoritär regiert Teile des
Militärs fühlen sich als Hüter der
demokratischen Ordnung und greifen an
Schüsse und Explosionen eine Nacht lang
tobter Kampf um die Macht in der Türkei
Teile des Militärs wollen den
Präsidenten stürzen rufen das
Kriegsrecht aus wir setzen Brücken und
TV-Sender Erdogan ruft die Bevölkerung
zur Hilfe Tausende gehen auf die Straße
für die Regierung ist klar wer für den
Putschversuch verantwortlich ist der
islamische Prediger fetula Mühle dabei
galten Gülen und der türkische Präsident
Erdogan einst als enge Weggefährten auch
gegen das säkulare Militär als Gülen
Erdogan jedoch Korruption vorwirft
märz 2013 zum Bruch zwischen den beiden
Männern entsteht an der bitterter
Machtkampf Anhänger der gülenbewegung
arbeiten laut Erdogan auch in der Justiz
gegen ihn das nutzt die Regierung als
Begründung für eine Säuberung in Justiz
und Militär es kommt zu einer
Verhaftungswelle politischer Gegner
zudem verhängt Erdogan für zwei Jahre
den Ausnahmezustand er kann dadurch per
Decret regieren und Grundrechte wie
meinungspresse und Versammlungsfreiheit
werden massiv eingeschränkt er führt uns
geradewegs in eine neoliberale Diktatur
wird auf seinem Weg umgibt er sich mit
dumpfen Nationalismus und religiösen
Fanatismus der nicht selten rassistische
Züge aufweist ein Jahr später leitet
Erdogan den Systemwechsel von einer
parlamentarischen Demokratie hin zum
präsidentialsystem es hatten sich so
viele Rechtsverstöße und Korruptions
Vorwürfe angehäuft es haben und nun
bestand die Gefahr dass Erdogan dafür
zur Rechenschaft gezogen wurde sobald er
die Macht verliert auch bei den Wahlen
2018 gewinnt Erdogan obwohl es bisher
Schwankungen gab in der Wirtschaft haben
wir diesmal Erdogan gewählt weil wir
glauben dass er wirtschaftliche
Stabilität bringt
er als Präsident kann künftig
Staatsoberhaupt und Regierungschef in
einem sein Erdogan kann seine Regierung
seine Minister ernennen ohne dass das
Parlament dabei ein Mitspracherecht hat
es werde uns Erfolg beigetragen haben
übrigens auch viele Deutschtürken 1,4
Millionen türkische Staatsbürger sind
2018 in Deutschland wahlberechtigt es
sind mehr als zwei Prozent aller
Wahlberechtigten der Wahl unter ihnen
hat Erdogan viele Unterstützer und
Unterstützer knapp 65 Prozent der in
Deutschland lebenden Türken haben für
Erdogan gestimmt deutlich mehr
Zustimmung als in der türk selbst
Erdogans Gegner und Gegnerinnen zeigen
sich niedergeschlagen unsere Rechte
alles ist in Gefahr es wird immer
schwieriger in diesem Land zu leben sie
schätzen die Frauen nicht Sie
haben Tim umgeworfen er hat sich einen
großen Machtapparat aufgebaut er hat
nahezu alle Bereiche des
gesellschaftlichen Lebens die Verwaltung
Justiz und die Medien in seine Hand
Erdogan erkennt die Gefahr einer freien
und unabhängigen Presse und schlägt
zurück von 2014 bis heute werden mehr
als 150 Medien verboten und über 160
Journalisten inhaftiert mehr als in
jedem anderen Land der Welt die
Pressefreiheit in der Türkei ist massiv
eingeschränkt und auch politische Gegner
und Gegnerinnen schaltet Erdogan mit
Hilfe der Gerichte aus und lässt sie
verurteilen welche Auswirkungen hat nun
Erdogans Politik sehr deutlich werden
sie in der Außenpolitik schon 2010 wirft
Erdogan Brüssel vor sein Land
hinzuhalten und bei den
beitrittsgesprächen zu diskriminieren
das Verhältnis zwischen der Türkei und
der Europäischen Union verschlechtert
sich immer weiter
in den Augen von Milliarden Menschen so
Erdogan steht Europa nicht mehr für
Demokratie Freiheit und Menschenrechte
sondern für Repression Gewalt und Nazis
ich möchte dass die Türkei in Europa
verankert bleibt aber ich glaube nicht
dass ein Beitritt in den kommenden
Jahren möglich sein wird 2019 stellt die
EU-Kommission in einem Bericht klar dass
die Türkei kaum noch Chancen auf einen
Beitritt zur Europäischen Union hat weil
das Land Rückschritte in Bereichen wie
Menschenrechte Rechtsstaatlichkeit und
Unabhängigkeit der Justiz macht und auch
die wirtschaftliche Lage in der Türkei
ist schwierig die Wirtschaftskrise mit
85% Inflation hohe Arbeitslosigkeit
trifft die Menschen hier am härtesten
die anhaltende Schwäche der türkischen
Lira gilt als weitgehend hausgemacht
Experten führen sie vor allem auf die
lockere Geldpolitik der türkischen
Zentralbank zurück und für die wiederum
ist Erdogan verantwortlich ein Grund für
die teurerung die türkische Lira
verliert immer mehr an Wert auch als
Staatspräsident Erdogan an seiner
eigenwilligen Finanzpolitik festhält bei
steigender Inflation heben Notenbanken
in aller Welt in der Regel die Zinsen an
um Geld teurer zu machen Erdogan macht
das Gegenteil nicht zuletzt zeigen sich
nach den beiden schweren Erdbeben in
Syrien und der Türkei Anfang Februar die
Mängel eines solchen ein Personen macht
Ausbaus allein in der Türkei sind über
50.000 Menschen ums Leben gekommen und
viele sehen die Fehler im System beim
Krisenmanagement
so zögerlich zu wenig zu spät glauben
viele hier habe der türkische Staat auf
diese jahrhundert-katastrophe reagiert
in den ersten Tagen nach den Erdbeben
ist kaum etwas zu sehen von den großen
türkischen Hilfsorganisationen wie
beispielsweise der
Katastrophenschutzbehörde AfA oder dem
Roten Halbmond das Problem der Türkei
sei das Präsidialsystem das auf Erdogan
zugeschnitten ist wenn alles von oben
bestimmt werde könne unten keine Handeln
hätten die örtlichen zuständigen die
nötigen Entscheidungsbefugnisse gehabt
wäre der Verlust an Menschenleben nicht
so hoch gewesen
230.000 Gebäude wurden nach Angaben der
türkischen Regierung durch die Erdbeben
zerstört oder können nicht mehr bewohnt
werden ein ähnliches Bild zeigte sich
schon 1999 als es ebenfalls ein schweres
geben kann es war in der letzten Nacht
um zwei Uhr vier unserer Zeit als in der
Türkei die Erde bebte das war der ganz
große Schlag und in Stunden darauf
zitterte die Erde noch mindestens 200
mal diese schrecklichen Szenen scheinen
keine Wirkung gehabt zu haben
Bauvorschriften die infolge des
Erdbebens damals verschärft worden waren
wurden offensichtlich missachtet
stattdessen ließ Erdogan vor seiner
Wiederwahl 2018
7,4 Millionen illegaler Bauten gegen
eine Abgabe amtlich genehmigen das
brachte dem Staat und 4 Milliarden Euro
ein die verheerend die Korruption ist
wurde im Beben offensichtlich als
erdbebensicher verkaufte Gebäude fielen
in sich zusammen rund 200 Unternehmer
wurden bereits festgenommen doch das
Problem liegt tiefer
hunderte Milliarden Dollar wurden unter
Erdogan in den Bausektor gepumpt und
viel davon floss über Schmiergelder
zurück in die Partei des Präsidenten
zudem wird der Regierung vorgeworfen
sondersteuerung verschwendet zu haben
die Milliarden Dollar der erdbebensteuer
gibt es gar nicht die Staatskasse hatte
kein Geld der Katastrophenschutz hatte
gar nicht das Budget zu helfen der Staat
ist unter diesem Schutz begraben die
Türkei befindet sich nach den Erdbeben
im Ausnahmezustand trotzdem wurde die
Wahl am 14 mai nicht abgesagt doch die
Katastrophe wird den Wahlkampf bestimmen
und er soll dabei die Opposition gegen
den Präsidenten ins Feld führen Kemal
Kilic da Rollo Chef der größten
Oppositionspartei CHP er wurde heute zum
Kandidaten eines sechs
parteienbündnisses geführt das Bündnis
hat sich trotz vieler Differenzen
zusammengeschlossen wenn es ein vor
allem ein Ziel die Zeit Erdogans zu
beenden
dann wird es laut
[Musik]
ernsthaft sagen du willst den
das Land ist gespalten unabhängig vom
Ausgang der Wahl was glauben Sie in
welche Richtung wird die Türkei Steuern
schreiben Sie es gerne in die Kommentare
und abonnieren Sie auch gerne unseren
Kanal wenn sie auch Hintergründe zu
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz interessieren
schauen Sie gerne unsere Kontext Folge
dazu an und wenn Sie noch mehr über die
Türkei wissen wollen dann empfehle ich
Ihnen dieses Video